le parti conservateur a publié deux
heures avant le débat hier son cadre
financier
on en parle ce soir avec vincent duhamel
candidat du parti conservateur dans
brome missisquoi bonsoir bonsoir
monsieur fillion monsieur duhamel vous
étiez président de fièr à vous étiez
dans le monde la finance est pas si
longtemps en quelques mots d'abord
pourquoi vous avez décidé de plonger en
politique mais que ce ne soit pas une
situation où je concert qu'on se
retrouve un croisée des chemins
maintenant on a une cession qui devient
de plus en plus précaire financièrement
et aucune aucun objectif était présentée
par le parti berra sur des cibles pour
revenir à un équilibre budgétaire un
équilibre budgétaire est important parce
qu'être pour me donner une résilience
pour la prochaine crise qu'on va voir de
toute façon pas toujours des crises à
différents moments et puis je ne peux
pas voir comment ce qu'on allait pouvoir
se sortir du
de ce que les libéraux ne présentait
sans même de sable avec des déficits
après difficile que je trouve un peu
compliqué c'est pour ça que je me suis
lancé me lancer ok parfait donc quand on
regarde justement l'évolution du cadre
financier sur le déficit budgétaire
vous arrivez en 2025 26 puis on va le
voir à 24 milliards de déficit on passe
de 68 à 24 milliards 25 milliards de
déficit et libéraux arrivent à 32 je
regarde les deux cadres financiers il
n'y a pas beaucoup de changements entre
les libéraux et les conservateurs en
termes d'évolution des dépenses
d'évolution des revenus en quoi c'est
très différent de ce que les libéraux
proposent la grande différence c'est que
les libéraux ont au cours des six
dernières années jamais été capable de
respecter aucun budget ils ont souvent
période oui mais même avant la pandémie
on vous pousse en temps de 2016 à 2019 à
chaque fois ils ont les dépenses ont une
croissance de 6 points 5 % alors que
l'économie avait une croissance de 1.5
1.6 pour ça ils n'ont même pas jamais
été capable de respecter aucun des
budgets qu'ils avaient mis en place
c'est très difficile de croire que
l'équipe d'ailleurs le seul qui avait
une certaine discipline de monsieur mono
difficile de croire que l'équipe de
monsieur triaud va être capable de
mettre en place un budget de respecter
un budget dans le futur soit ces numéros
1 2 même chose dans le plan conservateur
on a présenté les dépenses sans
croissance de l'économie se dit bon de
présenter avec une croissance qui la
croissance que le directeur
parlementaire du budget a aussi mis un
point 61.7 et on croit qu'avec beaucoup
des mesures qui ont été mises en place
vont être capables promet d'accélérer ou
d'edel accélération de cette croissance
hier on a reçu l'économiste serge
coulombe de l'université d'ottawa qui
nous disait que c'est pas vraiment
crédible de penser que votre recette va
tout à coup faire augmenter la
croissance de 1,5 à 3 % par année et que
ça ne se voit pas dans les autres pays
du g7 de toutacoup passé de 1 5 à 3 est
ce que votre plan à des assises latu
économiques solides pour vraiment faire
croître l'économie oui les utiliser
comme actionnaire mais premièrement le
24 milliards et post
2025 on assume toujours un point 7%
croissance à dire que dans le plat qu'on
a présenté c'est toujours avec plutôt à
1.7 nous ce qu'on va présenter c'est ce
qu'on présente c'est de dire qu'un
accélérateur par exemple
d'investissement où on nous donne les
crédits d'impôt pour le 270 milliards
d'économies qui dans le système bancaire
qu'on soit dix fois plus que ce qu'on
retrouve normalement doit aider à
repartir l'économie a accéléré cette
économie là le fait de ramener les gens
seront marché du travail des gens qui
n'ont pas travaillé depuis un an
beaucoup tu es peut-être 7 milliards au
début mes volets ramener rapidement on
va se retrouver avec une création de
richesse avec des gens vont payer plus
de taxes et avec une accélération des
quand même on aussi du problème
structurel plus long terme n'ont pas été
adressées depuis très longtemps par les
libéraux compense en innovation
recherche et développement qui sont des
débits points sensibles ou le canada et
provale le cancre de tous les pays de
l'occident dans le cadre que vous avez
présenté il ya pas beaucoup de nouveaux
revenus on identifie sept milliards 700
millions de dollars seulement de
nouveaux revenus avec l'appui rehaussé à
l' agence du revenu du canada il ya pas
beaucoup de compression non plus
et ont identifié des économies programme
de garderies 26 milliards 700 millions
est ce que c'est seul coeur du cadre
financier dans le fonds du parti
conservateur c'est à dire de mettre fin
au programme de garde à 10 dollars pour
l'ensemble du canada le cadre financier
le cas du chaos financier est plutôt de
ramener les travailleurs canadiens du
marché du travail et la meilleure façon
qu'on peut faire c'est en donnant par
exemple d'application que me à
l'augmenter un seul cas supposé les
questions travailleurs que le problème
ribéry ne ferait pas ça monsieur duhamel
de programme de garderies monsieur
fortin nous l'expliquait ça amène
beaucoup de femmes sur le marché du
travail ça coûte une fortune en ontario
la garderie notamment est-ce que ça
viendrait pas aider justement ramener
des gens dans le milieu de travail
créé un système de garderie comme au
québec va prendre cinq à six ans on n'a
pas le temps de se permettre d'attendre
cinq à six ans pour être capable
d'accélérer l'économie qu'on a besoin de
faire maintenant le plan qu'on a mis en
place est vraiment pour s'assurer que
tous les canadiens canadiennes ont les
fonds maintenant à très court terme pour
être capable de revenir ce marché du
travail le système québécois comme un me
vint pas à donner mature et efficace et
d'ailleurs étant un modèle d' exagérées
au phénomène d'attentisme c'est exagéré
20 ans quand même le système était et
efficace bien avant ça et d2 dès 2008 il
y avait quand même un ajout de
travailleurs dans le marché du travail
je vous emmène sur le 6 milliards
monsieur duhamel le 6 milliards
l'entente avec québec que vous
n'entendez pas finalement respectée si
vous prenez le pouvoir est ce que vous
allez compenser le québec pour le non
respect de cette entente d'une autre
façon comme c'est au tour c'est s'est
commis à ce soir avec monsieur legault
et pouvoir trouver des terrains
d'entente dans l'ensemble de tous les
transferts qui doit être fait vers le
québec c'est ce qui était ciblé hier et
puis c'est la mission qu'on va prendre
c'est pourquoi ce soir et que monsieur
legault trouver la meilleure façon de
faire les transferts qui ont besoin
d'aidé les québécois est ce que par
exemple on pourrait aller dans ce 10
milliards qui est dans votre plein dans
votre cadre financier pour une ligne qui
dit programme de stabilisation fiscale
et accor provinciaux ce qu'on pourrait
aller chercher quelques milliards pour
compenser le québec dans sa c'est un
accord qu'on va négocier avec monsieur
legault cantabrie le temps de négocier
le goût est ce que ça se pourrait quand
même qu'on prenne de l'argent là-dedans
pour compenser le québec sur les
garderies
c'est un accord convenu avec monsieur le
groupe lego
donc on ne dit pas aujourd'hui ils ont
sûrement élections on ne le sait pas on
verra après c'est sa
part fait monsieur duhamel vous serez au
débat économique la semaine prochaine
avec nous merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir merci au revoir
mentouri pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit